the country commemorated Anzac Day at
the weekend I joined the moment of
silence at dawn on the insect morning
from my driveway and could hear a
distant bugle playing the last post it
was very moving on my daily walk I could
see all the efforts of our community to
remember Anzac Day through poppies on
the fences chalk on pavements and from
Facebook members of McAlpin's North
Canterbury pipe band and brass bands
playing from their homes our strong
community spirit was clearly displayed
and echoed throughout our district and
throughout New Zealand at least we
forget we've made it through five weeks
together but apart we've made it out of
level four and now we are at level three
thank you to you all for playing your
part and making the lockdown successful
I'd like to acknowledge local businesses
who have quickly updated their business
models to work at level three I
encourage you to shop local to show your
support while staying safe I'm
personally looking forward to getting a
coffee and indulging in some takeaways
just a reminder that the council remain
here to support you we can put people in
contact with organizations that will
help them through tough times
be kind stay safe and look after one
another
you